se trata del más reciente escándalo en
brasil sus 20 operadores de salud
presento yo tenía 12 muertes de
pacientes no estudios sobre hay drogas
se colocan a este seguro médico privado
habría utilizado su red de clínicas para
hacer de ellas un laboratorio de
estudios sobre la hidroxi cloroquina un
tratamiento precoz apoyado desde el
inicio de la pandemia por el presidente
ya ir bolsonaro la empresa habría
obligado a sus médicos a recetar este
medicamento
walter correa es uno de los que
alertaron hoy existe una cita donde su
abogada
desde que denunciaron walter y sus
colegas han recibido amenazas teme que
la empresa se salga con la suya
impunemente a pesar de las pruebas
contundentes nueve pacientes murieron
tras el tratamiento bruna morató también
descubrió decenas de certificados de
defunción falsificados
aquí hay informaciones que prueban que
esta paciente por ejemplo se había
contagiado con kobe 19 y que
prevenciones lo niega no se atreva a
hacer lo mismo
atrévase y veras es la información que
me dieron mis colegas que se quedarán
allá que me van a perseguir destruir mi
carrera y mi vida y que asistirán al
espectáculo crear las susodichas pruebas
científicas que respaldaban el
tratamiento precoz y le hicieron
propaganda y ello indujo a la gente a
error y contribuyó a 600.000 muertes que
tenemos hoy en día según esta abogada el
primer señor habría sido impulsado a
realizar estos experimentos por personas
del entorno de jair bolsonaro que
componen una oficina paralela de gestión
de la pandemia
sabemos que el número 3 de la oficina
paralela a alguien presentado en todo
caso como miembro de esta oficina
paralela sostuvo conversaciones con el
dueño de prevent senior lo califica como
amigo y agradece por el trabajo
realizado y le dice que lo que hace es
maravilloso hay una relación claramente
establecida ya que desde el inicio de la
pandemia este medicamento ha sido la
punta de lanza del presidente sin
embargo lo que se conoce aquí como el
kit kobe ha sido reconocido como
ineficaz por lado ms y el bolsón aro
persiste hasta en la más reciente cumbre
de la onu el pasado mes de septiembre
desde el inicio de la pandemia apoyamos
la autonomía de los médicos en la
búsqueda de un tratamiento precoz con
base en las recomendaciones de nuestro
consejo federal de medicina
palabras y actuaciones denunciadas en
brasilia por esta comisión parlamentaria
que investiga desde hace varios meses
yo
y vos
promoción del tratamiento precoz
retrasos en las entregas de respiradores
y vacunas sospechas de sobrecostos en
las compras de lotes en esta sala se
desmenuza un nuevo escándalo cada día
decimos el presidente ya ir bolsonaro
está contra las vacunas pero francamente
son news las vacunas fueron entregadas a
los estados a las ciudades como porque
el gobierno federal las compro y las
entregó punto final marco rogerio es uno
de los pocos senadores miembros de la
comisión cercano a yair bolsonaro
denuncia una persecución ideológica y
política
el presidente no ha cometido ningún
crimen no hay ninguna prueba contra él
siquiera en esto de las acusaciones de
sobrecostos en las compras de vacunas y
respiradores ahora tal vez en un futuro
se descubran otras cosas pero por ahora
no hay ninguna prueba de crimen de
corrupción o lo que sea y puedes juzgar
la opinión del presidente basándose
solamente en un medicamento lo que dice
es asunto suyo luego usted decide si
está de acuerdo o no pero decir que hay
pruebas de corrupción o intentos de
corrupción y enviados a la comisión de
investigaciones eso no finalmente sí
promocionó medicamento es porque los
mismos médicos lo defendieron porque no
acusa más bien a los gobernadores de los
estados que compraron este medicamento y
distribuyeron dicho tratamiento precoz
tras varios meses de investigación el
relator de la comisión y el
vicepresidente afirman sin embargo haber
recolectado suficientes pruebas
tangibles contra el presidente nos
reciben en su oficina donde preparan el
informe de la comisión
y
no
tenemos tantas pruebas es impresionante
logramos probar el negacionismo del
presidente y la creación de una oficina
paralela que tomaba decisiones políticas
y decidía sobre la atribución de los
presupuestos en lugar del ministerio de
salud e incluso en contra suya
primer párrafo artículo 267 del código
penal respondía el crimen de epidemia
sancionable con una pena de prisión de
hasta 20 años por infracción a las
medidas de protección sanitaria
preventiva artículo 283 del código penal
crimen de charlatanismo sin olvidar el
crimen de responsabilidad tal como está
definido en el artículo 85 de la
constitución y que puede conducir a la
destitución del presidente
en total 11 crímenes han sido
identificados contra el presidente el
informe de los senadores deberá ser
entregado próximamente al fiscal general
de la republica el único que puede
perseguir a jair bolsonaro ante un
tribunal penal